PRICES HAVE DOUBLED SINCE
DECEMBER, WHY IS THAT HAPPENING?
SHUT UP, RACIST.
A CONTRIBUTING EDITOR AT THE
NATIONAL REVIEW ONLINE AND
WERE DELIGHTED TO HAVE YOU JOIN
US TONIGHT.
MY FAVORITE PART WAS WHEN
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE -- I DON'T
KNOW IF I AM PRONOUNCING HER
NAME QUICKLY, I DON'T WANT TO BE
RACIST -- SAID IF I CAN CHANGE
THE SUBJECT FOR A MINUTE, THEN
CALLED SOMEONE ELSE RACIST, THAT
SEEMS LIKE THE ONLY SUBJECT,
REALLY.
>> THINK OF RACISM AND HAVING
HERE TONIGHT.
WHEN YOU HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO
TALK ABOUT, YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
ANSWERS OR ACTUAL SOLUTIONS THAT
MIGHT WORK, YOU SCREAM RACISM.
ANOTHER THING THAT SCREAMING
RACISM DOES COME IT IS A VERY
POLITE OR MAY BE MORE POLITE WAY
OF SAYING SHUT THE HELL UP.
THEY DON'T WANT THE
CONVERSATION, THEY DO NOT WANT
THE TOUGH QUESTIONS OR ANYTHING
ELSE IN TERMS OF CONSTRUCTIVE
CRITICISM SO YOU SCREAM RACISM
DESIGNED NOT TO ADVANCE THE
CONVERSATION BUT TO SHUT IT
DOWN, ENTER GO BACK TO WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING IN YOUR EXCELLENT
MONOLOGUE EARLIER ABOUT
VENEZUELA, I HAVEN'T TO VISIT
VENEZUELA IN THE LATE '90s AND
EARLY '00S.
IT WAS A PROSPEROUS PLACE.
IN ORDER TO PREVENT US FROM
TURNING INTO THAT COUNTRY WITH
THE EMPTY STORE SHELVES AND
CLIMBING PRICES, BABY FORMULA
SHORTAGE, BABIES IN THE HOSPITAL
BECAUSE OF THIS FORMULA
SHORTAGE, UNBELIEVABLE.
JOE BIDEN COULD FIX A LOT OF
PROBLEMS, INFLATION, HIS
POLITICAL WOES WHICH ARE
TERRIBLE, THE POLITICAL STANDING
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, BY
SAYING I MADE A BIG MISTAKE BY
SHUTTING DOWN THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE, DECREASED DOMESTIC OIL
PRODUCTION, START BRINGING
ENERGY PRICES DOWN, ENERGY
PRICES START TO COME DOWN, THE
REST OF THE PRICE WILL COME
DOWN, INFLATION WOULD EASE TO A
DEGREE IN PEOPLE AT LEAST AUTO
INFLATION GOING DOWN, CONFIDENCE
WOULD IMPROVE, OPTIMISM
WOULD INCREASE, THINGS FEEL
BETTER.
EVERY TIME I TURN ON THE TV, GAS
PRICES GOING UP AND UP, EVERY
DAY A RECORD HIGH PRICE FOR GAS
AND DIESEL.
TALK ABOUT DIESEL SHORTAGES
COMING.
LESS THAN A YEAR AND A HALF, 15,
16 MONTHS, LOOKING A LOT MORE --
IT'S BEGINNING TO LOOK A LOT
MORE LIKE VENEZUELA THAN
ANYTHING YOU AND I OR ANYBODY
COULD HAVE IMAGINED.
>> Tucker: THE CONCERN IS NOT
JUST POVERTY BUT RADICALISM.
NO ONE IS GETTING MORE MODERATE,
SO REFUSING TO ADDRESS PEOPLE'S
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS, CALLING
THEM RACIST IF THEY ASK HONEST
QUESTIONS, ALL OF THAT MAKES
PEOPLE MORE RADICAL OVER TIME.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT THE COUNTRY
COULD, YOU KNOW, YOU CAN KIND OF
FEEL IT MOVING UNDERNEATH OUR
FEET HERE.
>> THAT IS WHY I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON THE FAR, FAR LEFT WANT
TO.
ONE OF THE GREATEST POLITICAL
SLOGANS WAS THAT OF VLADIMIR
LENIN BEFORE THE RUSSIAN
REVOLUTION, IT WAS VERY SIMPLE,
FOR WORDS, THE WORSE, THE
BETTER, THE WORSE, THE BETTER.
BUT THE WORSE THE CONDITIONS
WERE, MORE PEOPLE WOULD BE
RADICALIZED AND SAY WE HAD --
MAYBE WE SHOULD BRING LENIN IN
AND TURN THINGS AROUND.
PEOPLE WANT TOTAL, UTTER CHAOS
IN SOCIETY AND A PIECE OF THE
AMERICAN SPECTATOR ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND NOTHING BUT
TERRIBLE IDEAS COME AWFUL
SOLUTIONS.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN THE FAR
LEFT DEMOCRATIC PARTY TODAY WANT
THAT EXACT KIND OF CHAOS AND
REVOLUTION TYPE SITUATION.
>> Tucker: THE WORSE, THE
BETTER